WE'LL GET INTO ALL OF THIS AND
MUCH, MUCH MORE.
BREAKING NEWS IN TONIGHT'S
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
MINUTE.
SHE IS REPORTING AND WE HAVE
CONFIRMED WITH THREE SEPARATE
SOURCES THAT THE CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR FAKE NEWS RUSSIA
PROPAGANDA DOSSIER WAS, IN
FACT, USED IN PART TO OBTAIN
FISA WARRANTS TO SURVEIL
MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND TRUMP TRANSITION.
NOW THIS MEANS THAT HILLARY
CLINTON AND THE DNC, REMEMBER
THEY PAID MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR WHAT IS A TOTALLY PHONY
DOCUMENT FULL OF RUSSIAN LIES
AND PROPAGANDA THAT WAS THEN
MEMBERS OF AN OPPOSITION PARTY
AND INCOMING PRESIDENT.
THIS IS THE SAME DOSSIER THAT
BEING SALACIOUS AND UNVERIFIED
AND THAT INFORMATION IS ONLY
THE TIP OF THE ICEBERG.
SARA CARTER REPORTING AND WE'RE
ALSO LEARNING THAT MORE
SHOCKING INFORMATION WILL BE
COMING OUT IN JUST DAYS THAT
WILL SHOW SYSTEMIC FISA ABUSE.
NOW THE DOSSIER WAS USED TO
TARGET AN OPPOSITION PARTY AND
CRIMINALIZE POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES.
NOW THAT'S THE REAL STORY.
THAT'S WHAT THE MEDIA HAS NOT
AND WILL NOT COVER AND
DEMOCRATS DO NOT WANT YOU TO
KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THEY'LL BE
FORCED TO COVER THIS STORY.
ALL OF THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED IN
THE HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
IN U.S. AMERICAN HISTORY.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE LITERAL
SHREDDING OF THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION.
YOUR FOURTH AMENDMENT RIGHTS
AGAINST UNREASONABLE SEARCH AND
SEIZURE.
IT IS THAT SERIOUS.
THERE IS NEW INFORMATION IS
CONFIRMING WHAT WE'VE BEEN
SAYING AND PREDICTING FOR
MONTHS ON THIS SHOW.
THE POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE HAVE NOW BEEN
POLITICIZED AND USED TO
MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT.
THIS SCANDAL WILL REACH THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF THE OBAMA
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, D.O.J.,
F.B.I. AND WHAT WE'RE REPORTING
ON IS ONLY THE BEGINNING
TONIGHT.
WE'LL TALK TO SARA CARTER ABOUT
ALL THE DETAILS IN A MINUTE AND
ALSO TONIGHT THE PRESIDENT
CONTINUING TO CRUSH THE DESTROY
TRUMP LIBERAL MEDIA AND THE
LEFT'S COMPLETELY FALSE
IT HAS NOW BEEN OVER A YEAR AND
DURING A PRESS CONFERENCE TODAY
WITH NORWAY'S PRIME MINISTER
THE PRESIDENT WAS ASKED ABOUT
THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION AND IF
HE WOULD DO AN INTERVIEW WITH
SPECIAL COUNSEL ROBERT MUELLER.
HERE IS HIS ANSWER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Trump: THERE HAS
BEEN NO COLLUSION BETWEEN THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIANS OR
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT INTERVIEWS,
HILLARY CLINTON HAD AN
INTERVIEW WHERE SHE WASN'T
SWORN IN.
SHE WASN'T GIVEN THE OATH.
THEY DIDN'T TAKE NOTES.
THEY DIDN'T RECORD.
THAT'S PERHAPS RIDICULOUS AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE LOOKED UPON THAT
AS BEING A VERY SERIOUS BREACH
AND IT REALLY WAS.
BUT AGAIN I'LL SPEAK TO
ATTORNEYS.
I CAN ONLY SAY THIS, THERE WAS
ABSOLUTELY NO COLLUSION.
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT, EVERY
COMMITTEE.
I'VE BEEN IN OFFICE NOW FOR 11
MONTHS, FOR 11 MONTHS THEY'VE
HAD THIS PHONY CLOUD OVER THIS
ADMINISTRATION, OVER OUR
GOVERNMENT AND IT HAS HURT OUR
GOVERNMENT.
IT DOES HURT OUR GOVERNMENT.
IT IS A DEMOCRAT HOAX THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP AS AN EXCUSE FOR
LOSING AN ELECTION THAT FRANKLY
THE DEMOCRATS SHOULD HAVE WON
BECAUSE THEY HAVE SUCH A
TREMENDOUS ADVANTAGE IN THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
IT WAS BROUGHT UP FOR THAT
REASON.
IT HAS BEEN DETERMINED THERE IS
NO COLLUSION AND BY VIRTUALLY
EVERYBODY.
I WILL SAY THIS, I AM FOR
MASSIVE OIL AND GAS AND
EVERYTHING ELSE AND A LOT OF
ENERGY, PUTIN CAN'T LOVE THAT.
I AM FOR THE STRONGEST MILITARY
THAT THE UNITED STATES EVER
HAD, PUTIN CAN'T LOVE THAT.
OPPONENT, WAS FOR WINDMILLS.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT
ON SEVERAL KEY POINTS HERE.
FIRST OF ALL LIKE HE HAS BEEN
SAYING FOR MONTHS LIKE WE HAVE
BEEN SAYING THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE OF TRUMP/RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
THIS HAS BEEN A CONSPIRACY
THEORY MANUFACTURED BY THE
INDUSTRIAL FAKE NEWS MEDIA
COMPLEX THAT HAS BEEN SPREAD
NIGHT AFTER NIGHT, HOUR AFTER
HOUR BY THE LIKES OF CNN AND
COMPLETELY FLAT.
SO NOW THE MEDIA IS TRYING TO
ATTACK THE PRESIDENT.
HIS MENTAL HEALTH, WHICH IS
COMPLETELY RIDICULOUS.
IDIOTIC FOR SO MANY REASONS.
YESTERDAY WE COULD ALL SEE THE
PRESIDENT WAS IN FULL CONTROL
BUT THAT DOESN'T STOP YOUR
PRESIDENT IS MAKING NOW IS THAT
COLLUSION.
DON'T TAKE MY WORD FOR IT.
ERTION IS THAT THE RUSSIANS AND
HACKING AND DUMPING OF
DOCUMENTS IN THE ELECTION HAD
ESSENTIALLY RELATIONSHIPS WITH
TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN PEOPLE.
BUT I'M NOT PREPARED TO SAY
THAT THERE IS PROOF YOU COULD
TAKE TO A JURY.
>> DO YOU AGREE WITH THE
CONCLUSION THE PRESIDENT WAS
HAOEFPD THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION?
>> WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY OF THAT
WHATSOEVER, GEORGE.
WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT
EVERYTHING THEY HAVE.
THAT HAS NOT LED TO THAT.
SEEN EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION
BETWEEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
THE RUSSIANS AND YOU SAID TO ME
I'M QUOTING YOU NOW, YOU SAID
NOT AT THIS TIME.
HAS ANYTHING CHANGED SINCE WE
SPOKE LAST?
>> WELL, NOT -- NO, IT HASN'T.
>> JUST TO BE CLEAR THERE HAS
BEEN NO ACTUAL EVIDENCE YET.
>> NO, IT HAS NOT BEEN.
>> NO, NOT YET.
>> Sean: ALL OF THAT IS REASON
WHY PRESIDENT TRUMP TWEETED
TODAY THE SINGLE GREATEST WITCH
HUNT IN AMERICAN HISTORY
CONTINUES.
THERE WAS NO COLLUSION.
EVERYBODY INCLUDING THE
DEMOCRATS KNOW THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION AND YET ON AND ON IT
GOES.
RUSSIA AND THE WORLD IS
LAUGHING AT THE STUPIDITY
THEY'RE WITNESSING.
REPUBLICANS SHOULD FINALLY TAKE
CONTROL.
MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT IT, THIS
HAS SEEN BEFORE AND CONTINUES
TO BE EXPOSED.
AS WE'VE BEEN REPORTING FOR
MONTHS THE SPECIAL COUNSEL,
CORRUPTION.
ONE LAWYER REPRESENTED HILLARY
IN ONE PARTICULAR CASE ON HIS
TEAM.
NONE OF THEM CONTRIBUTED TO THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
KEY MUELLER PROSECUTORS ALSO
HAVE MASSIVE, MASSIVE CONFLICTS
OF INTEREST INCLUDING GENIE RAY
SERVING AS A LAWYER FOR THE
CLINTON FOUNDATION.
IT IS INSANITY, A PARTISAN
INVESTIGATION MEANT TO UNSEAT A
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WEIGHING IN
ON THE FAKE NEWS DOSSIER AND
HAMMERING FEINSTEIN FOR
RELEASING FROM TESTIMONY FROM
GLENN SIMPSON.
THE FACT THAT SNEAKY DIANNE
FEINSTEIN WHO HAS ON NUMEROUS
OCCASIONS STATED COLLUSION
BETWEEN TRUMP/RUSSIA HAS NOT
UNDERHANDED AND POSSIBLY
ILLEGAL WAY TOTALLY WITHOUT
AUTHORIZATION IS A DISGRACE.
MUST HAVE A TOUGH PRIMARY.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT CALIFORNIA.
GIVEN THE NEW INFORMATION WE'RE
REPORTING ON TONIGHT ABOUT THE
DOSSIER, IT IS CLEAR SENATOR
FEINSTEIN AND THE DEMOCRATS,
THEY ARE NOW TONIGHT TRYING TO
YOU ALSO HEARD FEINSTEIN ADMIT
A FEW SECONDS AGO SHE HAS
PERSONALLY SEEN NO EVIDENCE OF
TRUMP/RUSSIA COLLUSION.
REMEMBER, THAT'S WHAT THIS
WHOLE INVESTIGATION WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE ABOUT.
BUT SINCE WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANY
EVIDENCE, DEMOCRATS ARE NOW
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO KNOW
ADMINISTRATION OF THEIR FORMER
PRESIDENT, THEIR BELOVED,
BARACK OBAMA, WAS ACTUALLY
TARGETING THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND ONCE THE DUST SETTLES AND
ALL THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
SCREAMING ABOUT TRUMP/RUSSIA
COLLUSION, THEY WILL HAVE A LOT
OF EXPLAINING TO DO.